Hey babe, good news!
I just signed us up for a new retirement plan!
Oh!
...It’s a lottery ticket.
I know, it’s only like a one in a million
chance, but I’ve got a good feeling about this one!
Try one in 292 million.
When probabilities get that small, our brains
have trouble processing them…
But for reference, you’re more likely to
become an astronaut, or be killed in a vending
machine accident.
And according to some people, even if you
win, you might end up wishing a vending machine
had taken you out instead.
Let’s start with the basics.
What IS the lottery?
Essentially, it’s government-run gambling.
Kings, Emperors and presidents alike realized
that people hate taxes but love to gamble.
So lotteries were implemented to keep revenue
flowing in without causing the peasants to revolt.
For more ancient lottery history, let’s
check in with Danielle from Origin of Everything!
The earliest known evidence of lottery-style
gambling dates back between 205 and 187 BCE
during the Han Dynasty in China.
It was actually in the form of a game now
called Keno that’s still played in some
casinos today!
And similar to modern times, most of the revenue
went to funding government-projects.
Because the money for expanding and maintaining that big old wall needed to come from
somewhere!
Lottery tickets first showed up in the
Roman Empire under Julius Ceasar’s successor
Augustus.
He too needed a little extra cash to fix up
some infrastructure.
But the prizes didn’t come in the form of
money instead winners got materials
like household items.
And bookoo payouts similar to what we have today
didn’t arrive until the 15th century in
the Low Countries.
Today we know that region as “The Netherlands.”
Which makes sense since the word lottery actually
comes from the Dutch word loterij, the word
“lot" actually means “fate”.
Believe it or not, lotteries played a significant
role in the establishment of America
The proceeds from a lottery in 1612 were essential
in funding the establishment of Jamestown
by the Virginia Company.
And these days almost every state in the US
runs a lottery, and hundreds of other countries
continue the practice.
So what’s the harm?
Surely something that’s so widespread can’t
be that bad right?!
Let’s start with the obvious.
For 99.9999999% of people who play, the lottery
is a waste of money.
And even though most people know that the
statistical odds of winning are horrendous,
people continue to play in droves.
In fact, 60% of adults report playing at least
once a year.
But unfortunately the most dedicated players tend
to be poor.
Households with incomes of less than
$12,400, on average, spend 5% of their income
on lottery tickets.
And this is no accident.
Studies show that Lottery ads are specifically
targeted to low income groups.
Which is kind of perverse when you consider
that the lottery is essentially a voluntary
tax which is falling most heavily on the shoulders
of the people who can least afford it.
And there are ways that the government could
regulate the industry to keep it from being
such a raw deal.
In Ireland they have something called a “prize
bond” which essentially means players can
be entered into the drawing simply by loaning
the government a couple bucks, which can be
refunded on demand.
And where is all the revenue from the lottery
going anyway?!
It’s kind of hard to say because even though
it’s essentially a tax, the revenue is not
subject to the kind of scrutiny that real
taxes are.
Most states have it earmarked for purposes
meant to benefit the public good like education
or park land restoration, but there’s evidence
that suggests the increased revenue just ends
up being a shell game.
It’s not uncommon for state legislators
to cut back funding to the exact programs
the lottery was designed to help, most notably
education, and just increasing budgets elsewhere.
Finally, let’s address the core issue.
People aren’t playing the lottery because
they think they’re helping their fellow
man, but because they believe that the payout
will make their lives better.
So, does it?
There have been lots of studies done on lottery
winners over the last few decades.
And sometimes their conclusions conflict.
No, not everyone ends up miserable or buried
under cement somewhere.
But large unearned flushes of cash, also known
as “sudden income shock” can have significantly
detrimental effects on physical and mental
health.
One study showed that although winners’
life satisfaction improved, their overall
happiness did not.
In his book “Money for Nothing” Edward
Ugel interviewed thousands of lottery winners
and said “You’d be shocked at how many
wish they’d never won”.
This is possibly due to something called the
hedonic treadmill theory!
This is an all too familiar phenomenon where
as a person makes more money, their expectations
and desires rise in tandem, which results
in no permanent gain in happiness.
So if you were happy and satisfied in the
first place, the lottery won’t change that
very much.
And if you were unhappy before winning, a
massive cash increase can exacerbate your
problem.
So is it BAD to play the lottery?
Well, yeah!
It’s objectively a waste of money that feeds
an exploitative system which relies on our
collective participation, no matter how small.
BUT that doesn’t mean that dreaming about
winning is bad.
As a matter of fact, our lottery fantasies
can be a really revealing.
What’s the first thing you picture when
you imagine winning?
Do you fantasize about quitting that job you
hate?
Donating to a certain charity?
Starting that artisanal ice cream shop you’ve
always dreamed of?
Well, you don’t need to win the lottery
to get started on those goals.
The next time you hear about the newest massive
payout, pay attention to where your mind goes.
Most likely those wild and crazy dreams have
something totally achievable at their core.
And that’s our two cents.
Special thanks to Danielle Bainbridge from Origin of Everything for contributing to the episode.
If you want more intriguing slices of history, like where the minimum wage came from or why ALL shopping
malls look the same, you can check out Origin of Everything on Facebook and YouTube